Hello and welcome.
Very good to be with you
and have your company.
Now, my first guest in
this brand new series
is the Chinese dissident artist
and now author, Ai Weiwei.
Starting off as a filmmaker
in the late seventies,
he's now famed for his
provocative and political work.
Perhaps best known for
his art installations,
from the 14,000 life
jackets used by refugees
he attached to a Berlin concert hall,
to filling a gallery in London
with 100 million
handcrafted sunflower seeds
to question the "made
in China" phenomenon.
He has also disowned one
of his most famous designs,
the Bird's Nest Stadium
that was at the heart
of the 2008 Beijing Olympics,
citing serious concerns
over the Chinese government's
human rights record.
Following the destruction of his studio
and imprisonment in China,
he left his home country
but continues to document,
create and agitate.
He joins me now from his
latest abode in Portugal,
sadly COVID travel restrictions means
we cannot be together in person.
But, Ai Weiwei, welcome.
Thank you.
Your latest creation is
your book, your memoir,
"A Thousand Years of Joys and Sorrows."
What have you learned about
yourself from writing it?
Well, I think the purpose
to writing this book
is to find out my
relations with my father.
And I realized, during the detention,
I realized most of our memories
either being erased or
destroyed by the authority.
So I think the most dangerous
this authority is doing
to authoritarian state is
trying to change the facts,
what happened in the past.
So I have to establish
a real understanding
of my father's condition
in almost past 100 years,
and to write down what I know
and to leave this to my son.
Yes, that's the big driving force,
your son, who you say will
be your ultimate arbiter.
I talked about you being imprisoned,
being under arrest for charges
of a tax bill of millions.
This was after your artistic activities
and speaking out against the
Chinese government online.
But when you talk about your father,
he was internally exiled.
You were with him, you were
separate from your mother.
He was exiled for being a poet
and a so-called, "intellectual."
And you lived in a hole
in the ground together.
And I wonder, for you,
how much that prepared you
for your own imprisonment?
Well, my father was exiled
in Xinjiang province
where the Uyghur people today
have the re-education camps.
So we are probably the
first group moved to there
to be re-educated.
And my father spent about
20 years in that region
and forbidden to write anything.
So he's been doing hard labor
and also we're being punished
to live underground in a hole.
So all those experience,
I later, much later realized
that made me become me today.
And I would look at society
or a political system
with a different angle and a
very different perspective.
And in terms of your situation now,
you're talking to me from Portugal,
are you able to go back to China?
I don't think I can be
safely stay in China.
Maybe they would allow
me to get into China
because I'm a Chinese citizen,
but I wouldn't know I
would be safe in there.
And also I will not know
if they would let me out.
I talk to my mom almost daily,
and the last sentence she always
tell me, do not come back.
She knows I may want to go back.
So your mother's still there,
but you can't get back.
Yes.
What do you think would happen to you?
Who knows.
It's never, you never can predict.
I know so many people disappeared.
I know many people being
sentenced heavily for,
didn't do anything wrong.
You just don't know.
I mean, I suppose that's the thing.
I went to the exhibition
that you held at the
Royal Academy in London,
in which you recreated
some of those scenes
of your own imprisonment, the 81 days.
People may remember you
also kind of crowdfunded
to pay the millions that
you were said to owe in tax.
Some people were just throwing
the money in to your garden, I understand,
with paper airplanes.
But actually, I understand
you formed a bond
with the guards.
They had to follow you everywhere,
to go to the toilet, to the shower,
that came across in the art
that you created about it.
And those guards started
to ask you for advice,
is that right?
About their own lives, their love lives.
Yes.
They also, they're soldiers,
but they're only very young, 20 years old,
and they know nothing about outside world.
The only thing they do is trying
to protect someone like me.
They don't even know the name.
So they will have a lot of
curiosity about the outside,
about everything in life.
I think they are also just
like me, as prisoners.
As youngsters, they
really like to know more
about sex or any experience like that.
You know, I don't have a rich experience,
but I still can tell them more.
Good we've got the out at this point.
But I was gonna say, of course,
some of your formative years in that time,
you went to New York and had
your own education, I'm sure.
But I was gonna come to that.
The guards that were tasked
with making sure you were
where you were meant to be,
you say they didn't know who you were.
Do people in China know
who is Ai Weiwei is?
Before 2008, when I start
to design this stadium,
and more people knows me
because I was architect.
And then later when I
start to begin questioning
the state's corruption and
all those kind of mishandling
of schools building and which costs,
over 5,000 students lost their life.
And I've been totally
shattered off my internet
and also on the media.
So, I guess, not so many people know me.
I think that's fascinating
that you could be so famous
outside of your country,
and yet inside your country,
you've been removed or
erased or disappeared,
not physically, of course,
but just from the record.
Because, how much do you
think people in China know
that they don't know things?
Well, China under the,
the world outside of China
is two different world,
is two parallel world.
They hold very different
understanding about humanity,
about freedom of speech,
about political ideologies.
So they openly ignore
or criticize what is
happening in the West.
So China have 1.4 billion people,
and they firmly believes
in communist propaganda.
And that propaganda is very successful
and also they have very strong censorship.
So they would make sure voice
like me will never be heard.
And then I suppose that's,
you've got to question how successful
your activism is then if it's
for the rest of the world,
not for the Chinese.
Well, they see the potential danger
of my activism online because
at that time for a moment,
I was quite quite vivid, you know.
I raised a strong voice,
but that's why they have to put
this kind of punishment on me.
But I wonder, you say in your book,
young people in China
today have no knowledge
at all of the student protests
in Tiananmen Square in 1989.
And if they knew, they might not even care
for they learn submission
before they develop
an ability to raise doubts
and challenge assumptions.
I think so.
You know, they're kind of like a bird
has been caged for too long,
they cannot challenge to fly.
What will China listen to?
Do you think a cultural boycott
would work, for instance?
I don't think so.
I don't think anything,
the West doing this kind
of boycott would work
because simply China can suffer.
You know, the government
is not gonna suffer,
but the people really understand
what is like when they
don't have that much.
So in that kind of competition,
China can go very low,
and I don't think the West
can compete with China.
I was thinking about the cultural boycott
because, of course, museums and galleries
still collaborate heavily in China.
And yet, actually in the sports world,
we've seen anti-China messages
on certain sports people's shoes.
Serena Williams has
come out, for instance,
recently for, Peng Shuai,
the Chinese tennis superstar
who made allegations online
that she was sexually assaulted
by a Chinese official.
Those allegations very quickly deleted.
We should say she was also having
an affair with that individual.
I just wonder, do you
think any of those actions
are with merit?
I think those actions
are really helping the Western
public to understand China.
But for Chinese, they know
this is not gonna work
because the big corporations in the West,
they're eager to make a
bigger profit in China.
Nobody in the West in the corporate world
will boycott China.
So just a few sport men or
artists certainly will not work.
I mentioned the tennis player, Peng Shuai,
talking about what happened to her.
How brave do you have to
be to do what she did?
What she did is nothing to do with brave.
Go on.
You know, I think it's
also misinterpretation.
She is a sport person,
which is like a soldier in the army.
It's a race by Chinese state.
Any person in sport being considered
as the property of the party.
So what she did, I don't
think it's a lot brave.
She feel she has been mistreated
and then she posts on
her own personal blog,
or being deleted, then
later she performs according
to the states will to let
her perform she's fine.
And what is more disgusting
is the tennis association
under the Olympics jury
or Olympics committee,
trying to cover up.
They're not really make her,
demanding to have the truth out.
I mean, you may not agree that it's brave.
You see, you explain the reason
why you think she did it.
I suppose it's just,
you talked about what can
happen to you in China,
and there is concern about
what will happen to her now.
Oh, yes.
She seeing horrible situation
because she made this,
you know, I don't know
if she is regret or not,
but she seems to now only perform
on the same line as the state.
And, of course, being forced.
So it's business.
That's the only hope.
Business is dominating in
every corner of the world.
Why do you think even cultural boycotts
haven't caught on in the west of China?
We see them of Israel, for instance,
but we don't see the
same levels of outrage
a lot of the time over the imprisonment
of Uyghur Muslims, for instance,
who you mentioned earlier.
Well, I don't know.
Have you seen any
successful culture boycott
which kind of shaking
a society like China?
You know, it's not possible.
And with many, many regions,
culture boycott just simply doesn't work.
China has been isolated,
locked up for years
before, and they survived.
Are you resigned to China
staying like this then,
or you still, do you still
have fight in you, Weiwei?
I do fight all the time
because the fight is nature of my life.
It's not because I want to win,
it's only because I have to fight,
I have no other choice.
Who are you fighting for now?
If we've established
that those in China don't
know you and can't see you,
and it's now you have to
live away from your mom
and you have to live in Portugal,
how effective can you be, do you think?
I'm fighting for a lot of people
who's in same condition as me.
We have been forced out from our land
in a way when we cannot
have a normal communication
with our family.
And because of all kinds of reasons.
So we have to find a
way to express ourselves
and to let our voice to be heard.
I was just, I was thinking
of the Russian Putin critic,
Alexei Navalny, who went
back in Russia, now in jail.
Do you ever feel, have you
ever thought about going back
because you can make that kind of impact?
My life is not just making impact.
My life is about how to
successfully express myself,
so I could go back.
You know, it's not I'm
scared or afraid of anything,
but I also have responsibility.
I do have family and also have to care
about what my mom think about.
Do you think you'll
ever see your mom again?
I see her online,
but of course I always
want to go back, so...
How do you live with
that on a personal level?
That must be very difficult.
Not very difficult.
It's just the idea of I cannot go back,
it's difficult to accept,
but the other things is pretty normal.
Many people has been
separated from their parents.
If you look at the refugees in the world,
and there's millions
and millions of people,
they are separated.
You talked about your role being
to be able to express yourself.
Your art is political,
sometimes deliberately vulgar,
some would say, or offensive.
Do you think you've ever taken it too far?
No.
Far from being too far.
I've been too soft, and
my voice is very low.
And, yeah.
In what way?
Why have you been too soft?
Because the world is
just being indifferent.
If we say, the whole world
basically is a hypocrisy.
You know, people don't care,
they pretend they care,
but they don't care at all.
And my voice doesn't matter.
I was thinking then about the fact
that you brought up refugees
and when you recreated the image
that had gone around the world
of a three-year-old Syrian refugee boy,
Alan Kurdi, who'd washed
up dead on a Greek beach.
It was incredibly upsetting image.
You then posed yourself as him,
and some people did feel
that was utterly tasteless
even if you were raising
the plight of refugees.
I think I post that image purposely
to make those people
think that's tasteless,
make them feel bad because those people
are really hypocratic crowd.
They don't know how many children
has been drowned in
that sea, in that ocean.
His brother just a few
meters away from him,
people doesn't even care.
You know, the whole world is just so much,
so fake and so pretending.
And refugee situation is
then becoming even worse.
Nobody even asks the questions anymore.
So you did that because you wanted
to point out people's hypocrisy to them.
But people may, that photo
did have a real image.
People felt it was enough as it was.
It didn't need you to pose.
What did you actually,
I don't care...
what did you create by doing that?
I don't care what those
people think about.
I don't care about
whatever they think about.
And I think I don't
even know they're there.
I don't know if they are human at all.
If they understand what
happens to this world,
what happens to those refugees,
the only thing left is angry.
You know, you see the world
pretending nothing's happening,
but that will be leading
to even bigger disaster.
So, that sort of criticism
doesn't even enter your mind.
It doesn't bother you at all.
No. It make me joy, happy.
You know, I feel attached
to those very fake people
and they are shaking somehow.
So cancel culture
beside this new form
of Western censorship,
you talk about politically
correct extremism.
None of this sort of gets to you?
I think it's horrible.
Besides China, you can see
what happens in the West,
basically is totally fake
and the hypocrisy dominates
the world and the culture.
In what way?
You can see they're so unrealistic
where they start discussion
Yes.
about world politics.
You see this Turkish
journalist being killed in,
you know, the journalist being
killed in Turkish embassy,
actually his Saudi or
American journalists,
but America is still doing business
with Turkey, with Saudi.
And Trump said clearly they will not stop
to do the business with Saudi.
Is that clear enough?
Yeah, no, I understand...
The whole Western world,
the whole Western world stand silent
because they want business.
Is that enough to say what
is real human rights record?
And the hypocrisy that
you're talking about.
So I'm interested to go back to...
No, no, no.
There's a millions of
this kind of stories.
British pulled out Julian
Assange from the embassy,
now he's still ended up in British prison.
Is that hypocrisy?
Julian provide the, you
know, the so-called Wikileak,
which exposed the criminal
act by governments,
and that is a foundation
of investigate journalism.
Sorry, but he also didn't
go back to a country
where there were allegations
of sexual assault.
Those allegations are very...
No that's...
Could you let me finish.
That is wrong.
I have listened to you.
Could you let me finish?
Those particular charges...
No, I think you made
wrong accusation.
You make a very wrong acquisition.
I didn't get
to the end of my sentence.
Sweden already was charged.
They already withdraw the charge,
why you repeat to saying that?
That is fake.
No, no,
they didn't withdrawal the
charge, the charge expired.
There is a huge difference.
And I'm a keen, keen, you will
appreciate as a journalist
and as someone who
doesn't like censorship,
I will adhere to the fact.
Why they won't let him
to go back to Sweden, then
he has to go back to US.
Let him go back to Sweden
to facing the charge.
Sorry. You say that I
made an error, I did not.
For the record,
those charges had expired.
I think you made an error.
The facts are the facts, Weiwei.
No. I don't think that's a fact.
Using a fact which is not a working.
I'm using a fact that isn't working, okay.
What would you create if you could?
You said that you haven't
done all that you wanted,
your voice has been too low,
what is the piece of
art or the political act
or the installation that you would create
that you perhaps haven't done?
Oh, there's too many?
I have done very little,
I should humbly say,
I haven't started yet.
I was interested that you said before
that art is a sign of social health,
and I wonder what you think of the way
that it's now being traded as an asset?
I don't know.
I cannot really describe
other people's behaving.
Well, I think, I was
also thinking of NFTs,
non fungible tokens, these
unique digital assets,
a new big thing in art.
I wonder what you make of them?
I don't think that's new big thing in art.
I mean, that's new big
thing in financial world
or in technical world, I have no idea,
but nothing big in art.
As part of the market, I suppose,
do you think they're a fad
or do you think they're brilliant?
Do you own any?
No. No.
I'm not interested in it, but I may,
if I find the right topical right moment
that can carry right message, why not?
But I still cannot associate with it.
The last time we met in person,
I actually wanted a photo of us,
and you were very funny
because you insisted
on taking it on my phone as a selfie,
so I could have an Weiwei.
Yes, would have original work.
So who owns that, me or you?
Of course, it's done by me,
you owns it because it's your property.
Okay.
I just wanted to clarify that.
It was a very good picture.
But you also said to me
that you were done with art.
You were getting frustrated
and perhaps you would be happy
just doing something simple.
You said to me, you'd be
happy sitting on a bench.
Yeah.
Today in the interview,
they said that I cannot sit in a chair,
they want the background to be more clean,
so I'm a sitting on a stool.
You are sitting on a comfortable chair.
Do you know what though,
I'd much rather we were
together sitting outside,
it would be lovely.
That would be a nice.
Thank you very much for
talking to me again.
Thank you.
Thank you so much for being with us.
Until we meet again, mask
up, stay safe and goodbye.